the history of earth is basically there
is a military dominator at almost at all
times there's somebody that's the most
powerful military force and they are
controlling things there were empires uh
way before america became an empire but
from the beginning of america we were
still a free country that's not our job
to worry about man and like i'm sorry i
know like that that rubs people the
wrong way because they have this uh idea
that we have to be the good guys of the
world even though we're objectively the
bad guys uh in the world but the truth
is that like i said before we can't even
protect freedom in our country we're not
spreading it around the world um let's
see the the best thing america ever did
for the world was exporting the best
parts of our culture
was it was
that people wanted to listen to our
music and wear our blue jeans and be
cool like us that's the best influence
we could have on the world being a free
country here do you think on the dawn of
colonization of mars that it's okay not
to be strive to be the military
dominating force on earth as a country
or should we give that power to a
corporation or to another country
um i would say that uh i'm to keep us a
free country i am okay with sacrificing
colonizing mars when you say
when you say free country do you mean
that you're not
you're not like like anyone can do any
like what is your like because in in a
totally open system it can be co-opted
very easily by outside no i mean when i
say freedom i mean liberty i mean
negative rights i mean the right to life
liberty property you know so like no
spying on people that kind of stuff you
get rid of that but sure what happens
then when the ccp is spying and
infiltrating our media and making us
think things like communism good i've
always thought communism was good i mean
you know who's really done more to
[ __ ] to infiltrate our country that i
mean how do they even infiltrate it they
they infiltrate what
uh what do they pay commercials do they
pay off for president's son farms on
social
what they tell you media
universities the government program that
is universities that's completely backed
up by loans coming from the government
oh yeah social media companies
government comments
this is all nonsense dude the idea that
social media comments have had this huge
influence you know the truth is that
well all that's happened is that's been
used as an excuse for the government to
crack down on social media companies
huh we we see it all the time companies
caving to 30 people over nonsense
they they get so uh we were doing we're
doing an event yeah but those are real
people you're talking about they're like
social justice warriors like there's no
way to tell there's nothing to tell and
and and some of it very well could be
china they call the 50 cent army you
know what this is yeah i've heard of
that they go out there they post pro ccp
stuff but they're uh we've also heard
from other people who are familiar with
china's actions that they're encouraging
wellness in the united states tick tock
for instance allows it here but doesn't
allow it there so
yeah well look how they experience this
where you get one person pretending to
be 50 to try and force a business and it
works okay i'm not so i'm not arguing
that that has never had an effect on say
like a business i'm talking about more
like i'm like subverting the entire
country but if you look at the main ways
what they're what people try to
infiltrate is they try to infiltrate the
institutions of the government or i
suppose you could say universities which
is again basically a giant government
program it's all completely propped up
by government-backed loans or the whole
industry wouldn't exist i think that
yeah look you'd need to have a culture
to guard against that type of stuff and
that right and that's what you need is a
culture if you want to guard against
communism you really like to have a
culture that believes in liberty when
you also strong families and and strong
values and all the government does is
undermine all of this this is like i
mean from the welfare state undermining
families to you know the the kind of
like undermining churches and
communities and all of this this is what
big government has gotten us so in
essence i guess your question would be
in essence how do we prop up against
things like that china chinese
uh bots and all those different things
to infiltrate that to the point
it's our government doing it more than
anybody else and if if we're going along
with it and we're weakening it
because the government is telling us to
right again 2020 instead of us genuinely
saying [ __ ] no i'm not wearing a mask
i'm not wearing a [ __ ] vaccine my bit
my business didn't close the entire time
we didn't stop at black guns matter we
kept going that is a culture of we are
free now if something is really there
we're going to be safe and responsible
we're going to mitigate our freedoms or
our safety based on that freedom right
that culture compared to hey ccp where
we build stuff and people jump out of
the [ __ ] building and there's nets to
catch them from killing themselves when
you compare that to a young person you
show them that difference as opposed to
them being told yeah socialism is great
and there's nothing to really counter
that no real information then of course
it's going to be more difficult but
that's not that's not that's not
overwhelmingly coming from china yeah
would you use like american propaganda
to push that message on people
what do you mean by probably well like
little kids are the most susceptible
they made cigarette commercials illegal
and like this whatever well they making
little kids [ __ ] do the pledge of
allegiance
yeah so
propaganda to get people on board with
american ideals i think i think that
that word propaganda's kind of loaded
right because me saying i believe that
everyone should have a firearm to be
able to defend themselves and telling
them about their human right to
self-defenses of me articulating that
well is a form of propaganda right and
it's in alignment with my agenda which
is freedom and liberty right so when you
say propaganda what do you mean by do
you mean like bernays like just [ __ ]
lie to you propaganda yeah like how deep
would you take it i mean because i think
what right now they're using google to
subvert what they think is american
whatever ideas to combat the ccp that's
putting in like hey kids be a communist
but then we're going to but hold on let
me just ask because you're saying when
they're using who do you mean is using
google to combat the series we know the
fbi is in tight with social media
networks telling them what to post what
not to post
yeah right yeah it's very murky as to
who well and they certainly at least
according to mark zuckerberg when he was
asked why they suppressed the hunter
biden story the first thing he said was
well the fbi came to us and told us
there was going to be this big russian
dump and when there was this dump they
said this was all the dump they all said
this was the russian propaganda so again
they told their the staff not to
investigate it so right they knew what
they were doing so you know if your
concern is that like china is gonna
propagandize us i just like i go okay
but like this is to justify the regime
in washington dc but then like look at
who's actually propagandizing our kids i
mean like look at who's actually
propagandizing them right now it's the
public schools corporations
i got i got an idea
so so i think we've we've talked a lot
about the things we don't like a lot of
the problems
give me your guys's vision of what
america should be
well look i mean what america should be
is uh it should be the bill of rights in
the declaration of independence i mean
that that as a starting point like
that's what we should have in this
country we should like it didn't have to
be this way okay
this is there was nothing that was like
written in the stars that everything had
to go this way and i i'm i'm not saying
it has to be my utopia that i want it to
be this perfect you know libertarian
anarchist system sure that would be best
but i'm just saying we didn't have to
respond to 911 by starting seven stupid
wars and killing all of these people and
decree passing the patriot act and all
this we could have just let's say we
just say
even went into afghanistan and killed
osama bin laden and tora bora when we
had him uh cornered and came home the
war on terrorism was over by uh by
christmas of 2001. we could have just
not had artificially low interest rates
in the early 2000s and blew up this
housing bubble and had the financial
crisis in 2008 we could have just not
responded to covid in an insane way we
could have just had a government who
came out and went you know there's this
upper respiratory virus we think if
you're at risk you should probably stay
home that's our advice to you everyone
else you know be careful maybe wash your
hands if you feel sick stay home we
could have not tanked the entire economy
and printed six trillion dollars in a
year and destroyed everything so all i'm
saying is like
less of the evil stuff we could do a lot
less of this it doesn't have to be it's
not a choice between what we have now
and perfection it's that we should
always have liberty as like the guiding
principle and being very skeptical of
what the government does so that's what
we need that and all that comes down to
is just scaling back
i don't need more legislation to do that
again if we start from that bill of
rights the declaration of independence
and letting that be okay this is the
litmus test is this hey if we're giving
more and more government more and more
dollars more more power more and more
control 80 000 more irs agents how does
this get us back to more liberty
if that's the if it's a very basic
question it's a very basic answer nah
i'm not doing it tell me tell me where
it says in this that we should be giving
this over there if that's not the answer
then no we're not doing it
it's it's and i i i completely agree and
i would just add to that that like the
mission here to me really is that look i
mean think about like how the massive
propaganda campaign to push the coped
lockdowns right the massive propaganda
campaign to push the vaccines where it's
it's like you have to hear about this
constantly completely oversold of like
you know if you get this you can't
possibly get covet and you can't spread
it if you question this you're an
anti-vaxxer in all of this they use
these massive propaganda campaigns
because they know how important it is to
have the population believing that they
have legitimate authority over them and
believing that they're doing the right
thing so i think the mission here is to
counter the propaganda and to wake
people up like you said the mission
isn't to take over the federal
government and then you know
you know wield power over all of the
people and do it in the right way the
mission here is to wake people up to
realize that what we ought to be
striving for is to be very skeptical of
all of these authoritarians who promise
us that they're doing it for our own
good if we had a society like that we'd
be in much better shape
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8pm
and we'll see you all there
you